(man)
But that was a good practice,
though, dawg.
That was a good practice.
Pah!
I got you, dawg.
Quackadilly, you play
too much, man.
What's up, Fudge?
Hey, man, you play
too much, Quackadilly.
Come on, don't play
with me, man.
Not now.
I'm about to go--
come on, hey, stop!
Stop, stop--hey!
Hey, don't
tickle me, man.
[gasps]
Oh, you ticklish, dawg.
No, I'm saying, don't--
[both shouting]
Stop, man!
Stop!
What you doing?
You being stupid, man!
[high-pitched shouting]
You being stupid!
[dramatic music]
[whispering]
You touched my dick.
I didn't--
I mean, I did,
but I di--
My finger gra--
It does now occur to me...
that perhaps indeed
I do play too much.
I never intended
to grab the dick.
[haunting Western music]